let me bring you some breaking news
Israeli forces have killed three
Palestinians south of Janine they opened
fire at a Palestinian vehicle near araba
Junction in the occupied West Bank it's
ready for us to say they quote fold a
terrorist cell but planned to carry out
an attack it follows last month's
military assault on the Janine refugee
camp which was the largest in decades
only 24 hours ago a Tel Aviv patrol
officer had been had died after being
shot by a Palestinian on a street in
central Tel Aviv Hamas the armed group
that controls the Gaza Strip has
condemned the killings in a statement
its spokesman describes it as an
escalation of aggression and continuous
Terror against the Palestinian people it
says the occupation will pay the price
for its crimes our correspondent
Muhammad is joining us from occupied
East Jerusalem what's been happening
Rob we've seen a statement from the
Israeli Army which said that three
Palestinian men were killed south of
Janine inside their vehicle just in the
last couple of hours the Israeli Army
says that this was stopping a terrorist
cell on the way to carry out an attack
and that they also found an M16 in the
vehicle we've also now heard from the
Palestinian Health Ministry Palestinian
Health Ministry confirms the three young
men were killed near the town of araba
in Janine we've also heard from Hamas
they issued a statement a short while
ago which says among other things the
Zionist enemy committed a new crime by
assassinating three of our Palestinian
people in Janine the occupation will not
Escape paying the price for its crimes
Hamas also in addition to what they said
in this statement said that they are
calling for a need to formulate a
practical National plan to confront the
occupation obviously this is all adding
to a lot of tension here this is coming
just about 24 hours after an attack
attack that occurred in Tel Aviv in that
attack there was a young man a young
Palestinian man from Janine who was
shooting at people one Israeli policeman
was killed the attacker was then shot
and killed as well
um this is all adding to a lot of
concern here right now about what
exactly this could mean in the days
ahead of course Janine has been a
Flashpoint the scene of numerous raids
over the course of the last several
months just in the past month you had a
a a a multi-day assault by Israeli
forces into the refugee camp there and
officials have warned that 2023 is on
track to be the deadliest year for
Palestinians in the West Bank since the
U.N began keeping track of fatalities in
2005. so a lot of developments at this
hour were still waiting to hear more but
certainly this is something that is
going to get people concerned about what
might happen in the hours and the days
to come Rob obviously we're going to be
coming back to you as we get more facts
and details about what's been happening
coming in but for now Muhammad occupied
East Jerusalem thank you very much